play pokémon because a major apples
multimedia alle verdammtes glück
herzlich willkommen wir heute zu einem
neuen video wollte heute eigentlich in
weiteren partner pokémon gosee hochladen
jetzt am keyboard allerdings habe ich
mir dann gedacht hey es gibt so fucking
viele pokémon gomez wieso zeige ich euch
die nicht einfach mal das jetzt
eigentlich so das typische pokémon gummi
was ich irgendwie im internet gefunden
habe und zwar bevor pokémon noch so ein
typ der überhaupt keine beinmuskeln hat
und danach einfach abtauchen einfach ein
typ der die übelsten beinmuskeln hat
einfach weil man wegen dem spiel heraus
geht unsere übels viel rum läuft das
bild wenig auf kurs was ist das pokémon
baustart abwägen was ein typ der soli
ganz auf sein handy guckt durch die
innenstadt läuft dann halt diese
aufladbare akku dann irgendwelche
sportschuhe weil wir den ganzen tag rum
gefunden dass er vom auto angefahren
wird
das ist irgendwie das ist einfach so ein
komplett die wahrheit das jetzt ein witz
über die pokémon go server und zwar es
halt auch mal wer twitter das pokémon
gold bietet jou das ist jetzt in
österreich verfügbar in der schweiz
jetzt in japan aber eigentlich denken
sich sowie normalen spieler hey anstatt
erst einmal überall auf der welt
zugänglich zu machen macht auch erstmal
die server vernünftig so dass es
zumindest auch jeder irgendwie
vernünftig spielen kann als ich in
london war was beispielsweise sodass
voll viele leute da spielen wollten und
ich mich eigentlich nie connecten konnte
und ich habe auch von unseren pokémon
bhopal aufgenommen allerdings war das
total schwierig wir brauchten irgendwie
drei oder vier anläufe bis das überhaupt
noch mit der aps ein bisschen geklappt
hat falls ihr euch fragt wer der beste
pokerspieler der welt ist also natürlich
neben mir grills der kann auf jeden fall
wahrscheinlich eine menge eier ausbrüten
pokémon baum mit seinen entfernungen das
wird für mich auch ultra cool und zwar
sieht man ja immer so ja die evolution
des menschen von affen
hat dazu dass er immer aufrecht dagegen
dass er irgendwann wieder gekrümmt
ergebnis einfach nur noch am pc sitzt
und ein pokémon worden dann steht er
wieder mit einem rucksack ist halt auch
einfach die wahl in pokémon break ich
kann an diesem videoaktiv mehr sagen es
ist die wahrheit ist weiblich wenn man
irgendwo rum läuft darauf ein mal
vibriert das ist ja dass ein pokémon da
ist dafür sicherlich die spongebob der
gerade irgendwie quallen fischen ist und
sich dann so freund und lulu und auf der
einen seite ist man komplett verloren in
der wüste allerdings auf der anderen
seite hat man pokémon go wo man kann
überall alleine seine lange dauert kann
man jeder entfernung oder alles sich
irgendwie zu machen
play pokémon because a major labels
da draußen sagt gerade jemand ich hoffe
das hält man nicht so krass hier hat
jemand seiner frau ein master ball
geschenkt mit einem ring drin die ich
möchte ihn heiraten beim sex schule
active template imago es simpel not have
been fein
ich kann es wirklich nur selber
zeugen pokemon bau hält eine von allen
anderen aktivitäten also der hauptteil
des videos hier ist dass ich sage ja es
stimmt wirklich einfach dann habe ich an
unseren ähnlichen spruch gefunden one
month after play pokémon gold duo
exercise pokémon globe at s
ich will auch sagen bin jetzt ultra fit
geworden durch puppe motto an dieser
stelle würde ich das video auch beenden
meine damen und herren es weiß
vielleicht ein bisschen kürzer
allerdings ist es gerade noch 814 wir
sind alle schon ultra fit weil wir
gleich nach belgien fahren zum tumor
deswegen muss ich gerade so ein bisschen
videos vom produzieren wenn sich
allerdings trotzdem gefährlich sagt luca
pokémon bau ist echt cool wie du das
irgendwie machst dann lass auf jeden
fall eine bewertung gezeigt mit schreibt
einen die kommentare hier immer noch
süchtig sein
bei mir hört nicht auf